tote Herzen werden wiederbelebt der
Astronaut Alexander Gers fliegt zur Erde
zurück sowie die aktuelle Entwicklung
der ebolasäuche das sind drei der Themen
jetzt in den Klick zum Top 5
News die ESA entwickelt ein eigenes
Raumschiff die europäische
Weltraumorganisation ESA plant und
konstruiert derzeit ein Raumschiff das
den Wiedereintritt in die Atmosphäre
übersteht das vollautomatisierte
Raumfahrzeug hat in etwa die Größe eines
Autos und wiegt rund 2 Tonnen das
genannte intermediate experimental
vehicle soll im Oktober mit Hilfe einer
europäischen Vega Rakete vom
weltraufbahnhof Kuru starten das Ziel
dieser Mission ist klar ein Raumgleiter
soll entwickelt werden der vor allem
Astronauten oder Ergebnisse
wissenschaftlicher Experimente aus dem
Weltraum zurück auf die Erde bringen
soll und das unabhängig von Russland und
den USA ob allerdings genug Geld für
diese Entwicklung aufgebracht werden
kann ist
zweifelhaft g fliegt zur Erde am 10
November wird der deutsche Alexander g
nach fast 6 Monaten im Weltraum zurück
auf der Erde sein trotz eines Unfalls
bei dem eine unbemannte antarisrakete
etwa 6 Sekunden nach dem Start auf einer
vorgelagerten Landzunge im Bundesstaat
Virginia explodiert ist soll die
Rückreise wie geplant stattfinden Tote
oder Verletzte gab es bei dem Unglück
glücklicherweise nicht mit der
Raumkapsel signness sollen 2,2 Tonn
Nahrungsmittel und
Ausrüstungsgegenstände zur
Internationalen Raumstation SS gebracht
werden insgesamt zieht der deutsche
Astronaut eine sehr positive Bilanz
seiner Zeit im All die Experimente seien
sehr erfreulich verlaufen in den
vergangenen sechs Monaten habe er auch
gelernt die Dinge mit anderen Augen zu
sehen wenn man die Erde einmal aus der
Ferne betrachtet habe ändere sich die
Perspektive das Weltall bestehe nun
einmal aus einem schwarzen Nichts ein
paar Sternen und ganz wenigen Planeten
sagte er das ist eine Perspektive die
wir alle realisieren sollten und ich
sage nur vor allen wenn wir an Krieg
Streit Tod und Leid hier auf der Erde
denken zwischen den
Völkern Leben auf dem probemaß drei
Männer und drei Frauen leben seit Mitte
Oktober in einer weißen Kuppel auf dem
Vulkan Mauna Loa auf Hawaii in diesem
Versuch sollen die Lebensbedingungen auf
dem marß simuliert werden denn die
kargesteinige Landschaft in 2400 m Höhe
erinnert an die Oberfläche des Mars
zudem gibt es einen streng festgelegten
Alltag im Inneren des Raumschiffs der
Versuchsaufbau soll die sechs glauben
lassen sie sein bereits auf dem roten
Planeten gelandet zu essen gibt es
Astronautennahrung die Duschzeit ist auf
8 Minuten pro Woche begrenzt und die
Zimmer sind winzig um wissenschaftliche
Experimente durchzuführen darf die
Besatzung ihre Kuppel viermal in der
Woche für je zwei Stunden verlassen
allerdings nur im Raumanzug die
kritische Phase dieses Experiments
könnte in etwa 4er Monaten eintreten die
Forscher sprechen vom Syndrom des
dritten Quartal aufgrund der Isolationen
können die Probanden in dieser Zeit
unter anderem Depressionen
bekommen das ist eine Sensation totes
Herz wiederbelebt in Australien wurden
erstmals Herzen künstlich wiederbelebt
und erfolgreich transplantiert dadurch
konnten drei Patienten ein neues Herz
eingepflanzt werden zwei von ihnen haben
sich bereits erholt ein Patient liegt
aktuell noch auf der Intensivstation
dafür nutzen die Wissenschaftler eine
besondere Technik sie legten die Herzen
die maximal seit 20 Minuten nicht mehr
schlugen in eine tragbare Maschine mit
einer Speziallösung anschließend wurden
sie an einen neutralen Kreislauf
angeschlossen wieder zum Schlagen
gebracht und eingepflanzt der Name
dieser Erfindung lautet deshalb auch
Herz in der Box bisher wurden bis auf
einige Ausnahmen immer Herzen
eingepflanzt die nach dem Hirntod ihres
Spenders noch immer weiterchlugen die
noch lebenden Herzen werden dabei auf
Eis gelegt und schnellst möglich zum
wartenden Patienten transportiert das
Problem dabei ist dass diese gekühlten
Herzen nur rund se Stunden so aufbewahrt
werden können der große Vorteil der
neuen Methode auch stillstehende Herzen
können verwendet werden und diese können
auch noch weiter und länger
transportiert
werden die Zahl der Ebola Neuansteckung
geht zurück das trifft zumindest für
Liberia zu die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation WHO
überprüft derzeit die aktuellen Zahlen
um Fehlinterpretationen auszuschließen
damit ist es offenbar gelungen durch die
Isolierung von infizierten und sichere
Begräbnisse die weitere Verbreitung zu
verhindern seit Ausbruch der Ebola
Epidemie haben sich laut WHO insgesamt
13700 Menschen mit dem Virus infiziert
die Zahl der Toten lag am Mittwoch
offiziell bei
4922 experten gehen aber nach wie vor
von einer sehr hohen Dunkelziffer aus
weltweit ist aber noch mehr passiert in
New York wurde vor etwa einer Woche eine
Infektion eines Arztes gemeldet der für
die Hilfsorganisation Ärzte ohne Grenzen
in Westafrika war der Bürgermeister der
Stadt beruhigte allerdings dass alle
Vorkehrung getroffen worden sein und die
Situation unter voller Kontrolle sei
dennoch gibt es in den USA aktuell eine
Hysterie es wird befürchtet dass sich
der Ebola Erreger ausbreiten könnte
Präsident Barack Obama plant unter
anderem mit insgesamt 4000 Soldaten beim
Bekämpfen des Virus zu helfen eine
erfreuliche Nachricht gibt es in Bezug
auf einen Impfstoff erste Proben wurden
unter anderem in der Schweiz verteilt
dort werden 120 freiwillige geimpft und
die Wirkung getestet der Impfstoff
beruht auf ein gentechnisch veränderten
Virus und regt das Immunsystem dazu an
Antikörper gegen ein bestimmtes Protein
von Ebolaviren zu produzieren in
Deutschland ist der Senegalese der in
Hamburg behandelt wurde nach 5 Wochen in
einer sonderisolierstation ohne ein
Medikament wie das kanadische zmap
genesen allerdings gab es bei seinem
Heilungsprozess schwerwiegende
Komplikationen da der Patient unter
starken Flüssigkeitsmangel durch die
Behandlung der Patienten auf den
Isolierstationen würde sich allerdings
das Wissen um den Erreger erheblich
verbessern alle Videos zum Thema Ebola
gibt es hier in dieser Playlist hier
klicken und täglich News rund um Ebola
und Wissenschaft gibt es in der App und
den Blog dafür hier klicken alle Links
auch die zu den einzelnen Beiträgen gibt
es in der Videobeschreibung und was
meint ihr schaffen wir es den Ebola
Erreger zu besiegen im Moment gibt es ja
eher gute Nachrichten diskutiert es wie
immer mit mir in den Kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran